so let's now get into more of this
bizarre interview that donald trump did
with fox business host maria bartiromo
this morning
the big news from this interview was
that donald trump will not debate joe
biden next week as of right now
because the commission on presidential
debates decided it would be a virtual
debate
trump doesn't want it that was the sort
of big headline
but as this interview went on donald
trump was making less and less sense
shouting things out that had nothing to
do with what maria bartoroma was asking
about
and once again raising the question
about is trump
manic because of his use of
dexamethasone
is trump simply desperate because his
polling has imploded
does trump think yelling about hillary
on fox news will help his poll numbers
we don't know the answers to any of
these questions but i'm going to give
you a small
sampling of what went on here but what
is abundantly clear is this is not a
well
person here donald trump claims that he
recovered from coronavirus so quickly
because he's a perfect physical specimen
and then they just start talking over
each other
they being donald trump and the
interviewer maria bartiromo
tell me tell me how you felt what you
went through it's amazing
to me that you're back in such strong
form right now how did that happen
you've been talking about regeneron
eli lilly and regeneron want fda
approval for emergency use at this point
are they gonna get it they're gonna get
it yeah they're gonna get it uh i i'm
back because i'm a perfect physical
specimen and i'm extremely young
and uh so i'm lucky in that way
uh and and you know seriously
i don't have any i don't have heart
problems i don't have diabetes i don't
have any of the problems that you read
about
perhaps a couple of pounds we could lose
here and there but you know
there's a lot of people in that category
but no i'm in good health
and i'm uh you know like look what
happens is
if you're anywhere around this thing you
can catch it and there's the big
realization
trump finally understands contagion
isn't that amazing
if you're around it anywhere if it's
anywhere around you
you can catch it it's like seven or
eight months
since this started and trump finally
understands
if someone with the virus is anywhere
around you
you might catch the virus an incredible
learning experience for trump hasn't it
been
a trump on the joe biden town hall i
guess that joe biden did with lester
holt a few days ago
trump very angry about it but it's not
totally clear what he's talking about
here
nbc disaster where he went on this show
with lester hult it was like
it was meant for a child it wasn't meant
for a
grown person uh he gets up and he says
we're not fracking
we're not fracking he was fracking for
six months he was fracking he was
raising his
his very thin hand and he was fracking
and now all of a sudden he's not
fracking well tell the pennsylvania
people that you're going
it's ridiculous he said he's not
fracking
raising his very thin hand it's not even
possible to guess
what this man is talking about here
trump then accuses
china of putting a curse
on the united states take a listen to
this it wasn't our workers fault it
wasn't our airline's fault that china
did this terrible thing to us and i will
not be forgetting about that
china did this this was all done by
china and we shouldn't be hurting our
workers because china put the curse on
because this was a
a horrible scourge a horrible horrible
thing that they did
so the virus went from a biological
agent released by a chinese lab months
ago that was their idea months ago
now it's simply a curse so sort of going
from a conspiracy to the occult
trump then calls for barack obama and
joe biden
to be indicted for crimes which of
course he can never enumerate
unless bill barr indicts these people
for crimes
the greatest political crime in the
history of our country
then we're going to get little
satisfaction unless i win and
we'll just have to go because i won't
forget it but these people should be
indicted this was the greatest political
crime in the history of our country and
that includes obama
and it includes biden these are people
that
spied in my campaign and we have
everything
now they say they have much more okay
and i say bill
notice that donald trump still after all
these months of saying
biggest political crime in history we
caught them we have all the evidence
obama and biden did it to me
donald trump still isn't able to tell us
exactly what laws were broken exactly
what crimes barack obama
and joe biden committed but when you
talk about my political enemies should
be indicted
that's something we're used to hearing
from other countries
but but not so much from ours except
under donald trump then trump
bizarrely says he's killed terrorists
who are
bigger names than osama bin laden it's
all
what celebrity fetishism with trump take
a listen to this
we have the greatest troops in the world
i wiped out a hundred percent of the
isis caliphate
i killed solomani i killed al-baghdadi
names at everybody bigger names than
osama bin laden
uh al baghdadi founded isis everything
is hyperbole
everything is superlative with this guy
bigger names than osama bin laden
it's always been about can i do more can
i do it better can i do it bigger than
barack obama
and then it really got wacky trump
reacting to last night's vice
presidential debate between joe bi
between mike pence rather and kamala
harris and trump says of kamala
she is a communist and then with no
shred of sarcasm or joking at all
says that joe biden wouldn't make it two
months as president seems like he's
talking health wise
uh uh industry here what was your
reaction to the debate
what wasn't said that you would have
liked to come out and where do you think
the most striking moments were
i thought that wasn't even a contest
last night
she was terrible she was uh
i don't think you could get worse and
totally unlikable and she is
she's a communist she's left of bernie
she's rated left of bernie by everybody
she's a communist we're gonna have a
communist and she's gonna be
in my opinion within a month look i
stood next to joe and i looked at joe
joe's not lasting two months as
president okay that's my opinion
joe biden won't last two months says
donald trump
of course without any evidence and
remember trump is the one that's sick
right now
and that came up as well on the issue of
trump
having coronavirus trump says he hasn't
been tested for coronavirus recently
but that he is essentially very clean
he says pulled out of uh the senate
hearing that he was supposed to do mr
president i know you have to go
just to recap you're not gonna do the
next debate because it's virtual
you're feeling good i know i want to
make sure that the audience understands
you're feeling good
have you been tested recently can you
tell us anything else about that
but i'm essentially very clean they say
it's over a period of six seven days
and uh i was uh you know it's an amazing
thing happened to me i just
went in and i didn't feel good and
that's okay i expected at some point
because i'm out there i've got to be a
leader i can't you know winston
churchill didn't sit in his basement for
six months i got a lot of things doing
i'm essentially
very clean famous last words
from donald trump one really wild thing
as maria bartoromo
tries to end the interview this is wild
trump yells out of nowhere why hasn't
hillary clinton been indicted he just
yells it out of nowhere
i'd like to come back to the white house
soon to do another interview mr
president
i'd love to come back to the white house
hillary clinton being indicted
for terminating 33 000 emails that she
got from congress congress made a
request to see him
everybody else i know gets indicted when
they don't give that they don't give she
she destroyed 33 000 emails forget about
the fact that they were classified
let's go maybe mike pompeo finally finds
them okay
the interview was over as far as maria
bartoromo was concerned donald trump
interrupts and yells out
why hasn't hillary clinton been indicted
yet it's sort of a fitting conclusion
to a completely absurd interview and we
are seeing
a desperate trump yes the steroids may
be affecting his behavior
yes he still doesn't sound good he
sounds hoarse struggling to breathe
but there is desperation here because
donald trump on
some level must realize uh half his
campaign team has coronavirus
he's down in the polls he blew it in
that first debate he may now not even be
participating in the second debate
he must feel like this is slipping
through his fingers like sand
and uh he's desperate and this is what
we see
when donald trump gets desperate one of
our sponsors today
is a novel called 2120
by eithel right now america is facing
a tumultuous mix of covet 19
political polarization racial upheaval
and natural disasters induced by climate
change
the sci-fi novel 2120 takes us on
an adventure in the 22nd century with a
cohesive vision of the future
that addresses the underlying causes of
mega issues
ranging from hubris toward our
environment
parochial interests driving american
politics
2120 makes the flights of fantasy
into the future seem all too real as the
audience
vicariously lives the future through
vibrantly developed and thoroughly
believable characters
who humanize experiences despite owing
their origins to
other galaxies 2120 is the fourth
installment in a collection of novels by
either
called the galaxy series and i encourage
you to check out
the other books in the series as well
the author of 2120 dubs the book
an october surprise and the book
actually has a really great and
important message about voting you can
find 2120 and the rest
of the galaxy series by going to
davidpakman.com
galaxy i've put the link underneath this
video